sometimes you just need to remind
yourself to keep your eye on the bigger
picture hello there folks it is time for
my monthly dive into lgbtq+
representation topics which means that
first of all we can switch the look okay
so um your reminder of my dog in this
particular race I have a fluid sense of
gender that usually lumps me in with the
Q in the lgbtq+
under queer which kind of serves as the
catch-all in a lot of cases that in the
plus I guess I tend to just go with
queer it works well so I'm gonna talk
about it's something that I've run into
actually not even restricted to LGBTQ
plus representation I see it in other
places too but I'm gonna filter this
through this discussion and this topic
as a way to sort of illustrate how this
sort of thing is a problem and that is
how people as a society as viewers as
consumers of media we have a tendency to
defend instances but ignore patterns and
by that what I mean when you talk about
lgbtq+ representation and if someone
whether they are LGBTQ plus themselves
or not brings up something as being
problematic unless that thing that
element of an lgbtq+ representation is a
flat-out lie you know is just negative
propaganda is just hateful unless that's
the case and that's the case
increasingly less at least in most
mainstream media then you frequently
have people defending it when it and
defending the thing that is being
labeled is problematic because they will
bring hurt well no it's okay
because and they'll put it in the
context of the specific use and
basically saying what's wrong with that
well nothing unless there's a pattern of
it so I kind of just laid it out in
generalities let me get a little more
specific and I'm actually gonna narrow
this way down because then what I'm
talking about here as I said this this
is it something that expands even beyond
lgbtq+ representation and obviously that
entire spectrum is affected by what I'm
about to talk about but I'm gonna narrow
it down to my own specific experience
and I'm gonna talk about it um
specifically in terms of representations
of cross-dressing in mainstream media
now for those of you who didn't already
know
prior to getting enough of a sense of
myself to start identifying as
gender-fluid I identified as a
crossdresser
I didn't sort of come to a full sense of
myself in terms of my internal sense of
gender and the fluctuations with that
for a long time but for a long time I
simply identified as a crossdresser
which I actually wrote a book about I'm
called skirting gender life and lessons
of a crossdresser this is not just the
plug this is actually relevant because
this is something that I do talk about
in here and I'm gonna go into more
detail now because I do talk about pop
cultural representations of
cross-dressing in media there but I've
got to dive a little bit deeper because
in my book I really only talked about
the negative and I think kind of
difficult to defend representations of
men who dress as women which you know
some examples that I say in the book or
things like sorority boys Big Momma's
House those sorts of films white chicks
they do not paint a let's go but helpful
picture of men who dress as women now of
course it it's not their obligation to
be inclusive and I understand what
they're doing and all that but I mean
those also aren't examples that a lot of
people will necessarily defend they'll
either say it's a joke get over it or
they won't touch it
but I actually had a conversation a few
as of the time of this recording with my
partner about instances of
cross-dressing being depicted in media
where it's not it's not as inherently
problematic in the instances so some of
the specific ones we talked about are
things like some like it hot mrs.
Doubtfire Tootsie now these are films
that I do not find offensive in their
depiction of men dressing as women I
actually enjoy those films I enjoy all
three of those films to varying degrees
even some like it hot as old as it is I
don't think it's particularly
problematic in its depiction and way of
handling the comedy inherent with men
dressing as women but I've sort of
already started to touch on part of the
thing there because those three films
again I feel good films and the three I
already mentioned which I don't think of
very good films even you know
cross-dressing issues aside they're all
comedies and generally speaking when men
in mainstream entertainment were
depicted as dressing as females there
were two consistencies in pretty much
every depiction it was played for comedy
and they weren't doing it by choice
something was forcing their hand there
were circumstances that gave them
limited choices that they decided to do
this and that's true of all of these
films that I've already mentioned you've
got with things like white chicks and
Big Momma's House you have a need to go
undercover with something like sorority
boys it's it's wishing to be in sorority
fraternity culture but they got kicked
out of a frat so they pretend to be
women to be in a sorority some like it
hot they're hiding out from the mob mrs.
Doubtfire he's doing it to see his kids
Tootsie it's an actor who has just kind
of wrecked his career and he figures the
only way he could ever get work as if he
is not perceived to be who he is and he
goes with presenting as a woman now some
of these instant
looking at them specifically
individually are absolutely fine there's
nothing wrong with them but where it
becomes a problem is when the
predominant if not exclusive
representation of cross-dressing
is men forced into it by circumstance
and play for comedy because what that
does is it creates a general culture
where a man being an address is a source
of laughter and something to be mocked
and where you create a perspective that
no self-respecting man would ever choose
to do this because the only depictions
are ones who have in some way been
forced into doing this no man would
actually choose to do this and that
pattern and the pervasiveness of it and
at the exclusion of of having depictions
in pop culture media of men choosing to
dress as women and it not being either
comedic or something that they are in
some way for us to do our viewing for
between they're not non-existent but
they are by far the minority and so the
problem isn't each individual instance
the problem is the pattern that it forms
and that is the thing that I think gets
lost sometimes when we get into debates
about what is or isn't problematic
depiction of various members of the
lgbtq+ community because we can often
get hung up zeroing in on a specific
instance and going oh no no no but it's
okay here because of this or this or
it's fine in this context but like it
doesn't it doesn't matter if it's fine
in that context when the when the real
damage is big picture when the real
damage is well know there's nothing
inherently wrong with that but it's the
only version
that that exists so this was part of the
issue I had in what I consider to sort
of be the the gay explosion of the early
2000s when things like willing brace was
big and queer spoke came out and Bravo
as a channel headed in that direction
and and all those sorts of things
happened was yes there was a very higher
degree of visibility for gay men but it
was a pretty stock representation and
seeing more of them was a good thing but
the vast majority of them were depicted
as flamboyant effeminate basically
fabulous and when that's all that's out
there it creates an illusion of a
singular version of something and it
fails to acknowledge that that's not the
only flavor that gay men or anybody
comes in and you know to bring it back
to cross-dressing specifically it it was
one of the things that confused me a lot
and threw me off a lot when I'm in my
younger years trying to get a sense of
myself because I didn't have a
representation to cling to because I
could see films TV what-have-you
that depicted men in dresses but it
wasn't anything for me to take solace in
it wasn't anything for me to take
guidance from and again each individual
instance is not obligated to be a
positive role model or representation
but when every instance is effectively
the same thing that pattern and the
sense of what someone is that that
creates that is a problem and this is
also actually kind of an element in
something that I've talked about before
which is the issue of whether or not
only trans actors should be playing
trans role
something that I haven't gone into
specific detail I'm not sure is enough
to fill out its own video so I'll touch
on it here one of the things that is
often very frustrating for me when sis
actors are cast to play trans characters
the vast majority of the time not always
but the vast majority of instances they
cast someone who the gender of the actor
of the SIS actor is the gender that the
trans character transitioned out of as
opposed to the one they transitioned
into in other words generally when a
syst actor is playing a trans man they
cast a sis woman generally when an actor
is playing a trans woman
they cast assists man or at least
historically that's been the case
hopefully things will start getting
better and this actually will come out a
few months from when I record it so I
mean who knows not that I expect massive
upheaval in a few months that would be a
little optimistic of me but my point is
is that that pattern of casting beyond
the issues I already talked about with
casting cysts actors in trans roles
anyways which I mean you can check out
my earlier video on that but that
practice of casting the gender of
casting actors who were the gender that
the characters transitioned out of that
created its own problematic pattern
because it reinforces the idea that
trans people ultimately are still
whatever gender they started out as and
they're just pretending which is part of
the narrative frequently used to oppress
trans people you know the trans women
aren't women that's just a man and a
dress and when you cast a man to play a
trans woman it reinforces that because
we know that the actor is just a man in
a dress so and again
instances can be defended but it is the
pattern it is the pattern that matters
and I also want to be clear I don't
think there's that I'm not
conspiratorial by Nature I talked about
how the cat you know these casting
choices or these depiction choices with
cross dressers or what-have-you
caused a problem and lend credence
towards things used to oppress and
undermine certain minority populations I
do not believe that to be intentional I
don't believe there's some grand
conspiracy of Hollywood where they where
they're carefully monitoring you know
how they're gonna cast these things to
be sure that the pop culture feels about
lgbtq+ people in a certain way I don't I
don't believe that but I do believe that
people will just fall back on what well
they fall back on cliche and stereotypes
and that's an element of these things of
these patterns is stereotypes are easier
to deal with then flushed out nuanced so
while I do not believe there is any
particular malice in any of these
instances and as I said many of them can
still be very fine films it's the
pattern
it's the repeat and as I said this this
isn't even limited to lgbtq+ I remember
on my video that I did a while back
about five things Doctor Who needs to
stop doing one of the things I talked
about was that they needed to stop
bringing back companions after they left
because every single companion as again
as of this recording series eleven
hasn't started yet but every single
companion main primary companion has
reappeared after their suppose it exit
from the show every single one of them
has now people got uppity with me about
that specifically like they were going
well the one with Amy shouldn't count
because she didn't come back that was
just a vision he had of him and I kept
finding myself coming he's like I it's
not about whether or not every instance
was literally bringing a character back
from the dead it's about the fact that
it happens every single time it's the
pattern that needs to be broken it's not
a question of whether it makes sense in
any one instance and unfortunately that
is an argument that can be made either
in good faith or in bad faith someone
can defend a specific instance because
they genuinely feel that there is
nothing wrong with it or they can defend
a specific instance because they
understand that making that argument and
picking apart one specific part of what
is a much bigger argument is a way to
undermine what somebody is saying so
unfortunately those sorts of Defense's
of the instances within these patterns
like I say they could be made in good
faith or bad faith and a bad faith
argument is some is an argument being
made by someone who is not actually
trying to debate you but instead simply
trying to trap you trying to undermine
you and actually doesn't have a goal
besides that they're not trying to have
a conversation they just want to
undercut it's not about how strong every
single one is it's about the picture and
that's about the strength of all of it
together because if you want to look at
a brick wall you can find you could
probably find imperfections and issues
in every single brick if you wanted to
oh that one's got a crack that one's got
a dent that one's got a hole that's a
little loose there that's still a brick
wall all good luck pushing it down even
though you can bring issue with every
single individual piece of it the
strength of it is everything assembled
together but power is in the pattern or
in the case of problematic
representation the problem is in the
pattern so I think I'll wrap up on that
note I just kind of wanted to to talk a
little bit about that because I find it
helpful for me I don't know if other
people find helpful I find it helpful
for me to come to a bed
understanding of the terms and the ideas
and the concepts that I tend to talk
about in these videos because like I
said I had a conversation with my
partner um and she she doesn't play
devil's advocate but she does have a
tendency to push people for more details
on their stances so that she can
understand them better and occasionally
to see if they have actually sort of
thought through what they're saying to
the degree that they seem to have the
confidence of and I love that she does
that I greatly appreciate that she does
that so I forget sometimes that things
that because I have been thinking about
them for so long they're obvious to me
things like it's not the individual
instances it's the pattern that's
something that's been in my head for
years and I forget that people don't
think about things in the same way that
I do much less in the to the degree in
to the extent and as frequently as I do
and that's not a criticism nobody's a
bad person or you know a bad Ally or
whatever because they don't think about
this stuff as much as I do but sometimes
they need to step out of myself and
realize oh I should probably have
something on the record establishing
what I mean when I say X and I think
this videos is kind of just one step of
me trying to do that because ultimately
I think a big part of the difficulty in
these conversations is we don't have
agreed-upon language and we don't always
have agreed-upon terms with which to
have the debate so I like to be as clear
as possible about the the terms that I
use and why I use them and what I mean
by my use of them in case what you think
I mean when I say something is different
from what I actually mean which is also
part of why these videos are almost
never under 15 minutes and most of them
barb between 20 to 30 because I will
over explain and overanalyze is not
because I wish to like
surebut because i want people to
understand what it is that I'm saying
and I'd like to think that at the end of
the day even if you ultimately come to
the conclusion that you don't agree with
what I'm saying if you can understand
why it is that I'm saying it and the
thought process I have behind it that
maybe if nothing else we can come to a
greater level of respect for each
other's views and opinions because I can
demonstrate that I'm not just banging an
ethos from these thoughts these ideas
they come from places and they come from
you know there is a thought process I
tried very hard to not just parrot stuff
that I've heard and I'm not perfect I'm
sure especially if you go back to before
I had the sort of the same attention to
detail and these things that I tend to
have now I just probably is this is
where I said something that I probably
didn't put enough thought into or look
and do well enough before I said it but
I try and be cautious about that now and
I hope that my doing so can just get
people to understand me my thoughts and
maybe even other people who are like me
in some way a little bit better so we'll
stop there thank you very much for
watching there are a whole bunch of
links found in the description including
the patreon plus a link to the book if
you're at all interested so I will wrap
it up on that one folks remember you're
beautiful you are loved you are valid
you are the council and I just run the
meetings so until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]